[Music]
let us talk about Wilfred yeah really
funny show well thank you and great and
remember when I first heard the idea for
the show I thought you of course are
playing a human and and your co-star is
playing his dog yet he's a human in a
actor in a dog costume yes he's very
funny you guys are very good together
when I first heard the idea thought that
can't sustain over multiple episodes and
man does it sustain it's really funny oh
thanks it's terrific I'm just I have a
lot of questions first of all you have a
lot of hardcore fans yes and they seem
to love the fact that every episode ends
with you and your dog Wilfred smoking
pot together yeah it's a real thing that
show I don't know that a lot of masters
do that with their dog their dogs maybe
I'm wrong I'm gonna get a lot of letters
about this how dare you dude
and it's people have come out of the
fact that your your smoking you have a
very specific kind of bomb yes we have a
Gatorade palm homemade Gatorade bong
mm-hmm
yeah that's your average Gatorade bong I
mean it's essentially I'm gonna hear
you're gonna get a lot of free Gatorade
out of this or not people are like how
do we feel about this this is kind of
cool and kind of I don't know I don't
know it is a little cool cachet it's
they could yeah Gatorades not nearly as
cool as you and me tablet
oh yeah it's a Gatorade bong um to the
contents of the bong or I mean of the
Gatorade bottle rather and you get like
a bowl with like the stem cut a hole in
stick the the stand with the the bowl on
the end get some putty so that you can
actually kind of can seal the air in the
inside cut a hole on the other side and
you got yourself as long you went went
of your way to tell people out of
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right here I think we're done if you
have any questions write me please do a
little pamphlet like a Wilfred bong
pamphlet that's legal here yes here in
California Calculon yeah you as you can
see by the giant moon were in California
and we're all stoned we have a clip here
from will Fritton anything we need to
know about this about this clip it's
it's me and Wilfred the man in the dog
suit in a bath the actor who plays
Wilfred Jason Gann yeah yeah brilliant
yeah you guys are so good together okay
so the two of you are in we're in a
bathroom whilst an employee of mine is
also in the bathroom and some some
things occur all right let's take a look
at this clip from Wilfred a burst of
action what take who are you talking to
you know me water I'm always interested
in the investment opportunity to bring
my way yeah okay sounds good all right
I'll see you then hey hey Wilfred Kevin
sounds like something pretty big went
down in there sorry about that I went to
a new Colombian restaurant last night
I'm in on the phone oh right duh my
investment guys working on a huge real
estate deal I'm about to get pose aid
yeah kid I'll see him in the morning
[Music]
[Applause]